[Music]
[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is thirteen o'clock
i told you guys i was going to be
dressed up yeah suggesting the bride of
frankenstein you can't really see it
though with your hair yeah you can see
it a little bit
there you go right this is my
actual hair yeah it looks pretty good
from this
angle because i can see down right here
here and she's got this boom it's like
[ __ ] coming out it's it's
is covered with mostly black lace and
the only white
and black bra that i have has padding on
the sides which i don't really need
because
it just makes everything look ridiculous
however this is the only bra that i have
that will go into the stress without
showing too much
so you know so now i have to put i just
i wanted people to get the effect
you know she's got the big big shoes and
everything yeah
right now but yeah big like clunky
frankenstein shoes
we'll post up pictures tonight yeah i'll
put some up on instagram yeah because
we're on the halfway halloween party
afterward oh that's better now i can see
everybody
yeah sound is muffled oh no
is it really oh what happened look what
it did
why i did that that's ghost [ __ ] right
there okay is that better
yeah is that better yeah only [ __ ]
[ __ ]
how's it now how is it now got to be
better now
yeah it's like what the [ __ ] man it does
that without any authorization
yeah it changes the volume levels
without even asking
yeah it goes from 50 to 100 to 34
for some reason um you know
but yeah all i was doing was uh just
showing we didn't say anything like
substantive or anything i was just
other than you talking about the boobs
and me talking about
the bra yeah i was saying this second
let's say i go here how to take a
picture of that [ __ ] they're like
squishing up out of here it's great and
it's like bam bam bam
you can like bounce the dime off of them
you know boom fetish yeah we yeah we all
know we all know how you're just sucking
damn
[Laughter]
my injections are working well yeah he
keeps like looking over here and i'm
like what are you looking at something
to matter
[Laughter]
i told her i said man you don't
understand you don't understand anymore
i'm gonna get her on hrt you're gonna go
on hrt one of these days you will
understand
don't you tell me what to do okay just
saying
oh they see they're paying me paying you
they paying you for talking about your
boobs thank you gadget three straight
off the bat for the
yeah yeah yeah like i said after we
after we do the show we got a good
halfway halloween halfway to halloween
party yeah
that we were going to yep you could have
been frankenstein's monster but no
no i'm not i don't have time for that
[ __ ] man
he doesn't have time for that [ __ ] he's
not fun here's the thing here's the
thing
all the cool dude outfits are gonna be
expensive and they're gonna be hot as
[ __ ]
it's too [ __ ] hot out there it is
very hot out there and you know she's
not really wearing anything unusual
other than what she normally would you
know but i'm not gonna wear a jacket in
this [ __ ] heat
you know i'm just just not gonna do it i
don't care that much i've been around i
[ __ ] i've i've [ __ ] dropped my
goth nuts a long time ago they
i got my street cred they do they know
who i am they know what my closet looks
like
they know what my closet looks like i
don't have to wear it now they just know
what i have
yeah they just kind of they the one yeah
closet just [ __ ] black [ __ ]
jackets and coats and [ __ ]
they can project on to you like when
they look at you they can be like i
could wear he could be wearing this
right now
yeah i can look you know i got [ __ ]
[ __ ] that looks like 1800 sea captains
and [ __ ] and then i got stuff that
looks like vampires and i got stuff that
looks like
[ __ ] looking you know uh like
industrial dungeon masters and [ __ ] you
know looking for bondage
yeah bondage i like your bondage priest
oh thank you sheila
thanks tila she says shut up jenny you
look amazing thank you yeah
yeah she looks like i'm gonna take a
picture of this [ __ ] [ __ ] right there
here cause it's like
it's not just she didn't she didn't
understand me well then like i spent a
really long time with my hair though
that's something
cool yeah it looks good yeah look at
that i teased all that [ __ ] out i'm
gonna be regretting it tomorrow because
it's gonna be
it's gonna be all full of knots i'm
gonna have to wash it
it'd be all sticky you're lucky you're
on camera right now
uh-oh that'd be thrown down no it's
the camera's holding it at bay this
isn't our only fans page
one of these days we might have to open
one of those the way you're going
you're not ready i'm not ready you're
not ready oh i'm not you're not ready
yeah that's it
i'm ready you're not ready yet okay okay
all right go ahead
go ahead what does that even what does
that even mean
just it's it it's are you gonna say
something mean about me no no no
no sorry i'm just like i'm looking at my
hair
look at the thing it looks pretty rad i
think good i think it looks kind of red
man my [ __ ] arms hurting uh
who's that that's on you okay you want
to do that
it's okay today's show is gonna be
about eileen warnos or alien warnings
and she uh she lives around here she
used to live around here jenny
jenny went to a lot of places where she
used to hang out every time i was
watching some documentaries about her
and it's like i remember because i still
live there thank you victor only
fantastic
god damn uh did you stand up so i can
see the entire costume well i
i would but i don't have like the rest
of it it's like the dress is on but i
don't have like the
corset and all that kind of yeah yeah
she didn't have the shoes on i don't
have my shoes
i'll take a picture of it tonight yeah
he can do like a [ __ ] full length
later on uh but yeah uh hard jaguar says
tom you need your colonel kurtz outfit
on
[Laughter]
actually i have i have uh some of that
vietnam tiger stripe
and and that old m16 carrying gear
and everything i could dress up like
looking willard i don't have the helmet
we'll see there you go that would be
super easy nobody would get it
though see well that never should stop
you
you can buy an exact replica of
willard's uniform it isn't even says
what
you can it's it's the 21st century you
can buy whatever but it's the real
military thing it's mill
yeah it's it's you know 300 yeah not 300
it's almost 200 it's a lot of patches
that's not bad though yeah
for something patches pat those patches
are kind of handmade
reproductions they were handmade back
then most of them but
it's expensive the patches
yeah i mean uh when i was in korea we
had these guys called stitch we just
called him stitch
and stitch is a korean guy that would
come up to your floor every now and then
your barracks and he had a
a pedal a [ __ ] uh uh what do you call
it a sewing machine that was powered by
by your foot power you know it's like
pedal i remember those my mom had one
yeah
he could those dudes you could just say
i need an air assault badge he's like
okay
and he cut it out by hand and by hand
stitch
a perfect air assault badge in there
with a helicopter with wings on it it
was better than that and then he
flapped it down the table and went [ __ ]
yeah he did it would take him
take him about 15 minutes 20 minutes and
just by hand
and they were just beautiful if you had
those handmade korean
patches for your uniform they were like
people would [ __ ] dude could i have that
one you know
i'll buy it for 20 bucks they want you
to cut it off the uniform you take the
generic one they look really good
the name plates and everything the name
tags and the us army just looked really
good they were
all hand done on a sewing machine tila
is asking about your shirt
i was just going to mention that
actually yeah um sophie sent that sophie
said this to me it's
city club that's from back in the day
back in the day this was a club in
detroit
yeah goth club in detroit they used to
go to and she found somebody making a
reproduction of it
there you go all right that's from the
80s yeah he got that yesterday city club
that's right i like it leyland yeah it's
a little neighborhood outside
i really like it i like it
yeah oh so while we're doing shout outs
so thank you sophie for sending him that
shirt it's really cool
also we have a new patron who is right
here in the chat
it's no need for me to otherwise known
as ryan
is our latest patron so thank you very
much
for coming and joining this insane
family yeah but yeah what i was saying
about uh
alien warnos was that um i was watching
some documentaries about her
and i was still i think i was in my last
year of high school like when she was
killing people
right and every time they showed like
[ __ ] in daytona beach like the [ __ ]
motel or the hotel where her girlfriend
worked like all the
places she used to hang out i'm from
daytona beach and so i was just kind of
like oh i know exactly where that is oh
i know exactly where that pawn shop is
oh i know where that is so it's like it
was really bringing back some like
weird-ass memories
i haven't been there in a long time like
i think the last time i went back to i
went to visit my brother
like maybe a couple years ago but i
haven't been there since then
yeah this is behind that bar where she
used to live
well is that actually behind a bar and a
um
a motel right yeah behind there's a
trailer park a real trailer park it
looks like a goddamn park with a whole
bunch of trailers in it
yeah like you know and it's and bikers
and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
you can see uh what's his name went down
there
went down there pretty recently and
talked to everybody and the guy that
owns the bar they're they're nice people
that's a good video actually they
interviewed some of the people like the
guy that owned the last resort bar they
like interviewed him on this documentary
as well but yeah like dan bell went down
there it was probably a couple years ago
now
and i think he actually stayed in the
room where alien warnos lived
yeah and he was trying to because he's
kind of into paranormal stuff too so i
think he was trying to like hope and see
if she would if her ghost would like
come in
it's a it's a tour [ __ ] it's a tourist
attraction i mean you know that
yeah they will take you on an warner's
to excuse me this [ __ ] right here man
excuse me i'm distracted damn
well keep rubbing you might get a wish
[Laughter]
i'm trying to go straight to you guys
[Laughter]
you were talking about the damn bell
video oh yeah
you go there and they'll take you on on
a tour you know and they'll show you
where she lived they got
they got coffins they've got a coffin
out there where they used to sleep in a
damn coffin
yeah or on the big car seat thing back
there too because she well yeah she was
kind of like
homeless and and they have like um
kind of folk art paintings of her like
on the walls and stuff
and like when she got executed and all i
mean spoiler alert she got it
she got executed back in 2002
if you didn't know the thing about her
though
i don't know i think we talk about this
a lot when we talk about female serial
killers because you know there's not a
lot
and i think that she is so famous
because she's pretty much i mean i can't
really think i'm sure there's a couple
but
i can't really think of any other
offhand a female serial killer that was
essentially like predatory and killed
people that she didn't know you know
what i mean
because usually female serial killers
like and you know i might get into it a
little bit later like the other
woman that got um executed like the
death penalty she was a serial killer
too but everybody she killed
was she knew them it was like boyfriends
husbands her son
[ __ ] like that so it was always like
family members or it's usually done in
like a caregiving capacity like they're
you know
angels of death or whatever like they
poison people yeah if you look over time
it's usually poisoners like black widows
and then there's also like the serial
abortionists
the ones that say they'll take your baby
and get it adopted
like amelia dyer yeah for money and then
they take your baby
you give them money i'm gonna get it
adopted and then they just kill the baby
yeah yeah that that one that's that's
some wild because you know
trying to find somebody to adopt it just
too much work too much work
well it probably was back then it was
victorian era when in england
it was amelia dyer was it was english
yeah she was probably the most famous
one that did that
yeah so she would just we haven't done a
show about her we should women's babies
and they'd pay her
to take the baby and then she'd just
kill the baby and we're talking hundreds
of them if i remember correctly wouldn't
it
it was a lot i can't remember offhand
but yeah it was a lot because she had
like a whole business going yeah and
it's not like a lot of the because a lot
of the women were kind of like you know
in big trouble it's like you know they
were underage or they weren't married or
whatever
so it's just kind of like they were
trying to get rid of this kid so
if you know if amelia dyer said
something like yeah i'm gonna find a
home for them
you were like okay fine and then they
didn't really check up on them
afterwards like i said it was the
victorian era
i think it was more like uh the mother
would might have been relieved just to
have the kid
taken off her hands well i'm sure that
was the case also it was just
immediately forgotten
yeah baby farming they called it yes
says maria happened in australia as well
yeah yeah she would just throw the [ __ ]
over the bridge though
uh yeah she did either she did it or she
had like her
minions do it yeah and she's not not
cute minions but oh
hag wait i've one i've been actually
wanted to do a show about her
but um we'll probably get around to it
because like i said i'm fascinated but
well i'm fascinated by serial killers in
general but i'm fascinated by female
serial killers like i said just because
there's not that many
and i think that i've always been
fascinated with alien warnos not only
because i mean she wasn't born in
daytona she was born in michigan
but the fact that she killed people in
florida and that she lived in daytona
beach where i'm from for a really long
time and she
was there when i was there um makes her
really fascinating to me and also just
because she
she is really really different like from
a true crime standpoint
like i said it's it's vanishingly rare
for a female serial killer to kill
strangers or to kill for i don't know i
guess you could say that her killings
were
for practical reasons because she did
rob the dudes but i don't think that
that was the main reason that she was
killing them i think she was killing
them just because she wanted to
because she was angry and she hated
everybody you know what i mean
yeah i'm trying to get the angle right
on them damn boobs they go
i'm posting that [ __ ] up the [ __ ]
face can i see it first yeah see look at
that
symphony you can't even tell what that
is
oh you can you can see oh i don't know
exactly what it is they will know
exactly what it is well if it's you
they'll know what it is
all you can see is my cool like hills
cappuccino mix that i have over here
this one i had the mint one this one's
white chocolate caramel which is also
good but it's not as good as the mint
one it's hard to get
yeah it's hard to get the peppermint one
when it's not christmas time
all right just how many boots how man
sees jenny's boobs
oh man that's the only part of jenny
that matters
just right here jenny's
that's how i'm gonna say that [ __ ] i'm
gonna tag that [ __ ] i'm laughing i'm
laughing because in the
in the comments stop leave her alone
leave her her amazing dance alone
tagging 13 o'clock in that [ __ ] i didn't
realize
how um location how much decolletage i
was going to be showing with this dress
on the
there's nothing i can do about it now so
i hope
i'm just trying i'm saying hope
everyone's not going to be too bothered
by it or it's too distracting
it's like does it even matter what the
topic is because we could just be
talking about anything because
all the dudes would be like hypnotized i
guess
i mean if you're any if you're any
indication
says i'm [ __ ] finishing up okay the
other shit's going to be up there on
face
on instagram
yeah amanda said i get so tired of men
talking to my breasts
yeah it is it is kind of tired but you
know [ __ ]
see like i said if you didn't know what
that was it's like it's not hd
what are you on now i'm on the next
subject okay which is what
let me get back to let me get back to uh
stop
questioning me don't question me one
question i'm trying to get back to the
show
okay here we go all right
now i gotta go through all this stuff
you're the one getting distracted not b
that's on me it's not on you you keep
bringing it up just go back to the show
okay here we are well okay well it's
good i'm back thank you
thank you for coming back you're trying
to get me to clown on the show
okay well i don't have to try to get you
to do that no just do it you're trying
to get me to
[ __ ] clown around on the show yeah
britney says says the one who distracted
everyone exactly
i love how he does that it's like he'll
go off on this big long tangent and then
he'll be like
why are you guys making me go up on a
tangent i'm like that was you i was like
do you remember
do we have to rewind the tape and like
show it again i'm like that was you that
did that
you have to understand something i'm not
responsible
[Laughter]
tell it to the judge i'm not responsible
for this tell it to the judge
you're not responsible
oh my god yeah brittany lol you did this
bro
yeah exactly yeah also brittany checks
and stuff for the boobies
did you put on instagram or facebook
it's on instagram oh okay
i didn't even know it's i forgot that
you had it i tagged you a tag 13 o'clock
on facebook or on instagram so imagine
if anybody's follow if they're
following us on instagram you'll they'll
be able to find it okay you guys can
friend
me you can you can you can you can add
or follow me on instagram too
yeah i just i had an instagram from a
long time ago that was just under my
regular name jenny 13 o'clock pot 30 13
o'clock podcast
okay well yeah because that's my
instagram but it's actually my instagram
like i said i just changed it to 13
o'clock podcast because i didn't use it
under my name anyway
you know so i figured well i'll just use
it for that it's no no point [ __ ]
look at him look at him i'm just
thinking you are a 50 something year old
man
[Laughter]
i'm just focused there's no swarm down
in there focus
okay all right well yeah yeah
she doesn't understand he's thinking
about it later that's what he was saying
before
you don't understand me anymore you're
ridiculous
yeah you're a ridiculous person
you gotta stay on this topic yeah well
what has that ever stopped us we've
never said on topic ever
yeah we've never seen it on topic ever
but but you know what the nice thing
about it is that i feel like
we go off topic so much that people that
don't like that have already [ __ ] off
yeah
so we don't really get much complaining
about it anymore we've got a lot we used
to have complaining about it and i just
did man [ __ ] off
well you know like i said it i don't
even do anything like if you just come
on and complain about it then i just
like i don't even
i said you will just be like stridently
ignored yeah
because i i do kind of feel like one if
you block them they might get all like
martyr like oh
i'm too real for them or whatever and
then if you say anything to them then
they just like the attention so i just
pretend
that they never said anything and make
them feel like
there was a certain segment of females
that didn't like my sense of humor
they didn't like that i was i guess
sexist or something but it wouldn't
matter in real life
i mean in real life i'm not sexist
it's just uh just i'm just toxic and
toxic
features somehow attract women i i don't
understand it well it depends on what it
depends on
you got to look a certain way you got to
i guess you have to be a certain way
you got to be nice but
the more the the okay the more these the
more sjw some chick proclaims to be the
more likely is she's
going out with a dude that rides
motorcycles as missing eyes
as slaps her that's probably what it i
don't think that's the case they like
let's see some evidence they like dudes
that don't give a [ __ ] who are kind
who are a challenge that's what it is
they don't they don't they don't like
they don't like uh
pushovers they just don't excuse me
you like me i was a challenge
you used to like me
you don't like me
because i wasn't chasing you you still
crying that's because i wasn't
i wasn't chasing you you're so crying
you know
it was just crying it was just normal
you know i'm not what makes you think
i'm crying i'm not crying
you're always crying you're like why are
you always whining about something no
dudes are such whiners listen to these
women right
well this kind of this kind of ties in
with the whole alien warnings thing
because she's got a bunch of
[ __ ]
and um honestly she's a piece of [ __ ]
though she was a piece of [ __ ]
i don't know although i i gotta say like
right from the jump the first dude that
she shot
um they found out later that he was a
convicted rapist
yeah they might have been trying to do
something i kind of feel like now all
the [ __ ] she said later about oh they
all tried to rape her i don't buy that
but the first one i do kind of maybe buy
that it's
yeah eileen warnos i think sometimes
people say well you know she was abused
and
well you know i i still don't i mean i
feel sorry for well that's what i mean
she had a horrifying
childhood i mean just the worst yeah um
but a lot of them serial killers do
yeah that's the thing a lot of people do
the thing about alien warnos though and
i was one and i was
thinking about this when i was watching
because i watched like a zillion
documentaries on i've seen the movie
monster and like i read a bunch of stuff
about her
i j i wonder sometimes um
in a way that i don't wonder about some
male serial killers because some male
serial killers like had
you know normal or fairly normal
childhoods and they still were [ __ ] ups
her i kind of feel like if she had maybe
had a normal
upbringing she might have been okay i
don't think she would have been a serial
killer
you know what i mean i really don't
think she would have well you know and
and you know what's informing that is
it's very as i said it's vanishingly
rare for a woman to be a serial killer
in the first place and to be a serial
killer of this nature where she just
like
shot random dudes and like not people
she knew so i kind of feel like if she
hadn't had
the [ __ ] up uh childhood that she had
that she probably i don't know she would
have been okay
but i don't think she would have become
a serial killer i really don't you know
what i mean
yeah i'm just laughing with [ __ ] hard
jaguars said that's another shirt dude
i'm not toxic just projecting
masculinity
oh my god that's [ __ ] great
[Laughter]
just being a regular guy yeah i think so
just already did regular
i'm just being regular that's another
quote i'm going to use
i'm just being regular right regular
time it's regular
[Laughter]
[ __ ] don't take it tom yeah they got
my back
he's regular yeah just regular i just
like to [ __ ] with you
yeah and then [ __ ] that goes tom says
he isn't sexist that she's laughing
it's it's it's it's not a [ __ ]
malignant
sexism it's a it's a it's a beneficial
sexism
you know it's like a trade it's it's
like chivalry
it's like chivalry it's like that i
guess is it
i'm not analyzing it i don't analyze it
that way i don't care
[Laughter]
i narrow my eyes at you
[Laughter]
you don't care that's that's part of
your problem
[Laughter]
no you're just kind of looking forward
to the two tonight
as well i think it's gonna be fun we're
gonna have fun and um i don't know did
we mention this on sidetrack show but uh
paul and tina from bennie13 yeah
returning yeah they're gonna be there
they might do every friday i mean
we'll see i don't know okay
i don't know what's going to happen in
demetrius though because demetrius
usually did fridays
but i'm not going to say anything tom's
got sexual problems yeah i got sexual
friends
they're not sexual problems though
they're they're sex they're sexual
upgrades they're like sexual bonuses
they're like sickle bones they're not
broken they're not
problems they're they're bonuses yeah
couching
like a video game like you're leveling
up like a level up in noisy it's it's
it's it's sizism and shoe fetishes all
kind of [ __ ]
all right big booty big i like big
big boobs big booty big this big big
thigh
it doesn't all have to be at the same
time it doesn't all have to be on the
same one but it just depends
it's got to be have a novel appearance
and it has to look like health
and it has to be kind of kinky
and then you got to put [ __ ] badass
shoes on it and it's harder to describe
shoes to me
like i said before i'm not it's not so
bad where i don't need the woman just
need the shoe i gotta have the woman and
the shoe
all right it's all a thing yeah yeah not
now if the shoe isn't there i'd still
you know i could still be into the woman
it's just
when you when you put the shoe on a
woman it's even better
it's like it's an upgrade like you said
it's like an upgrade it's like putting
salt
on the food i'm talking about all right
yes yeah or sugar on your cornflake
or whatever yeah gram there's hammer
says alien versus dennis raider who
would win aileen would because she would
just shoot him in the face before he uh
even got closer she's like dork
dennis was a planner though he would
just ride around trying to figure out
where eileen was
first and then figure he he would have
oh just make a project
i'd figure out where she lived well he
had a lot of projects of people that
like he didn't kill
which is freaky what if you found that
out later on holy crap
fine you know find out when it was a
good time he'd been like hanging out in
front of your house like looking through
binoculars and whatnot trying to figure
out when she was
you know indisposed where i could creep
up on her
you know he he would you know he he he
got him by ambush
so no i think he'd he'd kill eileen
hornos the thing is though is that
you're assuming that that that dennis
would be into eileen and i'm saying hell
no
dennis wouldn't touch eileen with a
10-foot bull that's true he'd be like
oh she's way beneath my stance god that
that
although the thing about it is that the
people that picked her up like the dudes
that picked her up were all
in that same type of they were all kind
of like
older like 40s 50s
working middle class dudes dennis dennis
liked
hotties and he was into milks and gilts
and [ __ ] you know i mean church-going
upstanding women that he could
kind of because you gotta understand
that [ __ ] when raider [ __ ] got his
hands on these women
he thought in a weird way he was taking
them through like the ultimate
experience
this was gee thank you from his point of
view this is like a gift
bryce says who is dennis we're talking
about dennis raider the btk killer
somebody asked because we do like a
whole i don't know if you're new here
but
of course you know she was upset you
know we have a bobble head and
everything
i told her you know i had so at the end
i told her that you know
i'd have to i'd have to kill her and of
course she got upset you know
but uh so i gave her a handkerchief so
she could feel a little better
gave her some water yeah she was a
little upset yeah yeah that i was trying
to like rape and kill her yeah yeah yeah
imagine that
i can't imagine why but he thought this
is i think i think he thought this was
like [ __ ]
really awesome well for him it was
probably awesome
i think it's not so much for others i
think it's some weird perverse
i think in some weird perverse way he
fantasized
that they were like highly aroused by
these uh
[ __ ] massive emotions of [ __ ] fear
that that was erotic to them
yeah i mean you know it was erotic to
him
in as much as he could well yeah i think
that his problem and i think a lot of
serial killers problems in general
is that they are projecting their own
[ __ ] up feelings on them feelings onto
their victims
yeah now it's time i have to kill you
isn't that in that cool that's really
cool yeah
yeah because he thinks it's cool yeah he
goes yeah i know you're crying but
that's your role in this
that's the [ __ ] the idea you know
enjoy it savor it
okay here it comes yeah that's kind of
like yeah see that does not shock
because well cause like i said i kind of
feel like they see other people
it's like a cartoon and yeah not maybe
not even i was going to say as objects
which maybe they do but they just see
and
they see other people as just a means to
their own ends
and like i said it's a projection an
extension of their fantasies
yeah they kind of think that they're
that the victim is experiencing the same
thing they are
yeah in a certain way thank you dom the
bomb what do you think tom i need a
dennis raider impression
you've been doing it you've been doing
it just gave it to you you've been doing
it
somebody asked i have all these people
sending me money to try to do a dentist
writer impression
as if i'm some kind of monkey
like an organ grinder are you getting
upset dennis
i'm very upset oh no we can't have that
dennis is something to be respected you
only pull dennis out every now and then
hold on i've got to get the [ __ ]
bobblehead
he needs the bobblehead it doesn't it's
not as good without the bobble head
yeah thank you ajiro yeah we should make
a tom quote board that would be fun
i know i'd run out of room he has so
many good ones
see very difficult for your people to
understand
that the show is tom and jenny's show
and i allow tom to channel me sometime
from my prison cell
because through tom i can experience
jenny's boobs
oh is that the reason yeah of course
yeah
yeah of course yeah i'm kind of
flattered i would have made you one of
my projects jenny
you know you're a nice woman you're a
nice woman thank you
how tall is your grass
[Laughter]
i don't mow my grass take it up with the
lawn crew
boy you guys hope he never gets out
right yeah
i know we're in big trouble thank you
maddie p3400
yeah thank love the outfit jenny thank
you very much you guys don't understand
this [ __ ] bro
i'm tasting it just don't mess it you're
messing my hair up you're messing you're
always worried about
messing up hair and [ __ ] don't worry
about the hair then i gotta start over
no no no no we'll fix it later we'll fix
it later
man i hate i hate when i have everything
just the way i want it and then i get
those over anyway i'm gonna tear you
down when the show is over
anyway okay yeah i'm gonna have that
[ __ ] on camera
for the night come on let's go yeah
somebody asked okay i'm glad they asked
again because i don't want to scroll
back up
rusty asked so why don't you think the
men she killed tried to rape her well
you know what i think
i think the first one uh probably did
and i
it honestly it would not shock me if
some of the other ones uh tried to as
well
um because that's you know she was a sex
worker
these were the kind of dudes that it
happens and it's not all that uncommon
but i think it's a little coincidental
to think that every single one of the
seven dudes she killed tried to do
tried to pull something it's not
impossible um i
you know i leave the possibility i
haven't doubted it but it's just yeah it
just seems a little coincidental i i
killed those dudes because it was easier
than than blowing them and she was
robbing them as probably honestly i
think what ended up happening
is the first dude i think did try to
rape her because like i said they
later on they found out that dude had
was convicted of rape like
in another place so i think he did try
to do it she shot him
and then at that point i think she
thought well this is easier than and i
think that just kind of opened the
floodgates you know what i mean yeah
so it could have been that she got to a
point where if anybody like if any dude
made any kind of like wrong move or
looked at her wrong then she was just
like [ __ ] it this dude's like dangerous
yeah do something about it first time
first time you you shoot somebody or
kill somebody there's kind of this
[ __ ]
boom like something hits you in the head
and this wave comes over you of like
this death
feeling of death that kind of goes out
throughout the world and it's kind of
numbing
and then what ends up happening is
there's kind of like an underlying
guilt that you that they that they feel
and sometimes to assuage the guilt doing
it again
actually assuages the initial the
the first one you don't talk about yeah
that way you're only
you're only feeling the last one yeah
over and over again it's kind of like
hitting your set when you're a kid if
you kick
something would hurt on your legs so
you'd hit it again and then
it would kind of be numbed and that's
how a lot of like
tribal tribal armies
narco armies some of the tribal african
armies that would form during civil wars
that's kind of how they motivated their
soldiers to contin
a lot of times child soldiers to
continue to kill
you kill somebody and it's [ __ ] kind
of a bad feeling but if you do it again
you feel better
and if you do it again you feel better i
think that was the case when you do it
again you feel better so it's kind of
like a [ __ ]
and then all of a sudden you they're
getting the hang of it
and yeah and then they then you develop
a taste around it well it becomes easier
the more you do it
and like i kind of feel like because
rusty said did she stick to that story
or ever change it
at first she was basically trying to say
that all of them were self-defense and
they were all rapists
now before she got executed she did say
you know they weren't all
trying to do something um or she kind of
said well the first one tried to
which like i said i kind of believe that
she's like the other ones
didn't really or they just tried to
start to or whatever so she
kind of rolled it back a little bit like
later on before she got
it's an addictive substance that's what
happens
yeah it's an addictive substance and i
think that's what happened in her case
yeah she was just a very i mean like i
said she had a horrible horrible
childhood which we'll talk to in a
minute
um and i just feel like she was just
angry
and she hated everybody she never formed
any
connections with anybody really and she
didn't trust anyone
and she had a really really bad temper
um
you know and genetics i think played a
part too because
we'll talk about that like her dad yeah
had who she never met but he had some uh
issues let's put it that way yeah it
kind of happens with any kind of person
it happens with serial killers because
they're demented and they're it's part
of their sexuality
it's that same kind of addictive
substance to it it can happen with
soldiers and it ends up being
you know kind of kind of like a ptsd
type thing but it's also this kind of
will to be an
eternal war you know um
apocalypse now a good example um with
willard
you have to humanize these people
they're not monsters it all depends on
what
what segment of society that they're in
it could happen with cops
and it happened with eileen warnos i
think just because she was a victim of a
rape and then she retaliated or defended
herself and then it just became part of
her
thing yeah i mean i kind of feel like
that was
and in some ways as i said and you know
i don't want anybody to think that i'm
excusing what she did obviously because
she killed seven people in cold blood
um but you know i kind of say this when
we talk about a lot of serial killers
male 1 or female ones it's like
some of them didn't really have a chance
like they kind of came into the world
and they just
came into the world like in the most
[ __ ] up situation ever and they had
these horrible
childhoods they never had any you know
chance of getting out of
it and you know
that's the thing like a lot of people
grow up in situations like that and they
don't
end up serial killers what you can i'm
just trying to understand them i don't
excuse it but i can understand sometimes
why people go the way they go now
that's not to say because some serial
killers like ted bundy and [ __ ] like
that had pretty normal
uh childhoods and they still
did horrible [ __ ] what's weird is it
could happen on mass too
there are whole civilizations that this
happened to [ __ ] that happened in the
french revolution stuff that happened in
germany
what japanese soldiers did in nanjing
china
it was just it can become part of a mass
psychology
too so it's not just individuals
um i mean you can sometimes an entire
mass can [ __ ]
well yeah i mean i think all people have
that proclivity
i mean it's just a natural thing but you
know just because something is natural
doesn't mean it's good and you know
you had american soldiers that just
[ __ ] killed a lot of people in in in
both theaters
but what's funny is that it didn't have
it tended not to have a big impact
on the american society because a lot of
those guys
never made it back they got killed and
that's yeah
you know they're out there and [ __ ]
really bad battlefields
some of those guys killed 30 40 people
with this one you know because they were
in the right spot where they could mow
them down with a machine gun
then they killed some other ones after
that and then a week later they killed
some other dudes
but then they were killed so you know
what i mean that you you so they didn't
come back they never came back home and
they never really had an effect on
anything
so it's happened a lot yeah and this is
something because we talk about a lot of
crime and we talk about a lot of serial
killers and this is something that i'm
kind of fascinated by
it's just the whole nature versus
nurture thing
it's not it's not anything i don't think
that's ever going to be
completely sorted out because one thing
feeds the other thing yeah it's an
endless loop going
like one thing feeding back into that
and then that feeds back into that
it's like you're never going to be able
to tease it apart i mean at some
point i guess when they can completely
you know uh
do everyone's dna and like figure out
what causes what and everything like
yeah maybe you can say what percentage
of that
was genetically based where the hell was
my lighter at
um are you gonna do that yeah yeah i
could use that well i figured these are
good because
you don't get addicted to them i forgot
all about those you forgot all about
them yeah well i got like two packs so
you should be good
i'm gonna get one but yeah so
but as far as alien warnos goes and like
i said i was thinking about this earlier
is that i really do kind of feel like
it looks lit i really do kind of feel
like she
um is one that had she had a normal
upbringing
she probably would have turned out like
i said she might not have been like a
[ __ ]
rocket scientist or anything but she
probably would have just had a
completely normal
life you know i don't think she would
have become a serial killer
had her childhood not gone the way it
had gone you know
that's all i'm saying and i said the
same thing too about you know because
we've done
shows about killer couples sometimes
and sometimes the women half of that
couple i don't think if they hadn't met
that dude i don't think they would have
killed anyone on their own
most of the time answering the question
no i wasn't representing willard the red
i was well
i was referencing captain willard from
apocalypse now